this is this sister never been done
before then look back many many years
ago and see what Tyler Perry did and
what did Tyler Perry do he made history
all right this weekend the grand opening
of the Tyler Perry studios
Spike Lee enough whole bunch of people
were there to celebrate Perry is the
first black American to own a major film
studio outright the Atlanta Film complex
fans listen to this 330 acres with 12
sound stages it's larger than the
Burbank California Lots owned by Warner
Brothers paramount and Walt Disney
Studios combined it is ginormous
Oprah Beyonce samuel l.jackson Spike Lee
all were all walked the red carpet this
weekend attending the star-studded grand
opening that samuel l.jackson we spoke
to Perry in Atlanta about this historic
moment
he told us why he feels ignored by
Hollywood and responds to his critics
the New York Times said you are the most
successful mogul Hollywood has ever
ignored do you think Hollywood gets you
know I clearly believe that I'm ignored
in Hollywood for sure and that's fine I
get it wait a sec is that fine it is my
audience and the stories that I tell our
african-american story is specific to a
certain audience specific to a certain
group of people that I know that I grew
up with and we speak a language
Hollywood doesn't necessarily speak the
language a lot of critics don't speak
that language so for to them it's like
what is this but I know what I do is
important I know what I do
touches millions of people around the
world I know how important every word
every joke every laugh I know what that
does for the people where I come from
and the people that I'm writing for so
yeah I get that but you've also been
criticized in some cases by your own
people by other fellow colleagues were
you seeking in this moment validation or
that wasn't something either that you
paid any attention to you mean building
all this to seek validation no no no not
at all for me what this is about or just
show listen I know what I'm doing is
what I mean I don't you know if they get
it that's great if they don't have
really feelings from the bottom my heart
they get it the great if they don't then
that's fine too I know for a fact that
I Drive in through these gates on to
this 330 acres and see these 12 sound
stages and and see the highway sign that
says Tyler Perry studios as you're
making the exit in here as I come in
here and I see these hundreds of people
work in these black and brown I've been
on sets where I've been the only black
face only black face on
as recently as 2019 going where are the
black people in this movie it's on back
behind the behind the camera so when I
come to work here and every black person
that comes to work here they go oh my
god is heaven here we are we're
represented where everybody's
representing lbgtq is represented black
white u J straight whatever we're all
represented working hand in hand arm and
arm so what I know about what I'm doing
is any any doubters comes to just come
take a visit and see walk these streets
see these people see these underdogs and
you tell me what I do don't
he's so true it's right he wants people
to come and see what he's done because
it really is extraordinary
I mean it's jaw-dropping I'm gonna talk
about a little bit more about it at the
talk of the table because he had a very
special moment this weekend as part of
the opening dedicating sound stages to
12 people who he believes have paved the
way and made a difference in Carroll
also anything that interview was done in
the Diahann Carroll studio yeah
unbeknownst you know of course we knew
that she died that day but that location
had been picked out long before we
arrived we happen to be shooting there
on the day that she died that was a
little that was a moment tomorrow on CBS
this morning we're gonna go inside Tyler
Perry's massive studio he shows us why
he's so afraid why he's so proud of this
accomplishment a lot of people are very
proud of Tyler Perry too and why father
hood makes him so emotional